It's great to welcome to the program today,
Sanford Levinson, who is a legal scholar professor
at the University of [inaudible] city of
Texas law school and coauthor along his wife
Cynthia of the book fault lines in the Constitution,
the framers, their fights and the flaws that
affect us today. A Sanford. So great to talk
to you today.
I'm delighted to be here.
So to begin with, for people who may be aren't
a familiar with the genesis of the constitution,
what was going on in the United States that
prompted the founding fathers to realize that
the articles of confederation were in some
way not working or falling short, and that
writing a constitution was something that
made sense.
Right? There are three principle things. First
of all of the so called national government,
and I use that term advisedly, wasn't capable
of getting any money. What they could do in
effect was to ask the states to contribute,
but by 1786, I think they were contributing
something like a total of $636. So that's
the first thing, no money. Secondly, there
were fears of various military attacks, um,
from a variety of European countries, but
also from a, a variety of Indian tribes, many
of whom for very sensible reasons had supported
the British during our succession from the
British empire. Um, and so there was real
concern about the ability of this new country
to defend itself. The third thing is that
there were trade wars, which is something
we're really with today in an international
context, but there was no established notion
of free trade among the various states. Um,
and there was some genuine hostility between
and among a number of the states so that people
like Alexander Hamilton and others described
the system of yards from the federation is
quote Imbecilic Unquote, and something had
to be done
when the transition from the articles of confederation
to the Constitution took place. How much discussion
do we know how much discussion there was about
writing the constitution in such a way to
indefinitely account for however society might
change? And the reason I asked that is that
now there is a big debate over to what degree
do we need to be amending the constitution
on an ongoing basis to account for how drastically
life has changed today from when it was written.
Was there much discussion of accounting for
that at the time of its writing?
It's terrific question. I think that the most
accurate answer is no. That the first constitution
that is their article federation lasted a
grand total of six years. I think that if
you could have interviewed the framers, they
would been thrilled to be told that the 1787
constitution would last 50 years. I think
if you said, well, you know, you're really
writing something that should last forever,
I think they would've said, you know, that's
crazy in part because they were extremely
aware of what they repeatedly call the lessons
of experience and the need to update government.
In terms of those lessons, Cynthia and I do
not engage and founder of ashing. We think
that the founders by and large were admirable
people trying to respond to what they thought
were the chief challenges of the day and that
they weren't good opiates. They were trying
to develop a document that could get us through
the next several years where several might
mean 25 or 50 but they expected amendment
and quite frankly, I think a lot of them expected
new conventions. Article Five, which is the
amendment article explicitly allows for new
conventions. And I think that most of the
framers would be astonished to be told that
there's been no national conventions since
1787 whereas there have been over 230 state
constitutional conventions since 1787
so there is the view from some that it is
immensely difficult to amend the constitution.
So my question is sort of a two part question.
The first part is how do you assess the difficulty
of amending the constitution in the context
of sort of modern society? And number two,
uh, if indeed the founders were so welcoming
or expecting of significant amending of the
constitution as the country changed, why did
they set the level of difficulty that they
set?
Right, right. Another great question. What
they faced in something 87 was an artisan
convect federation that required unanimous
consent of the state legislatures of every
state. So from their perspective, Article
Five, which requires quote only unquote three
quarters of the states to set to amendment
was a big improvement. Secondly, article five
worked in the first, let's call it 15 or 20
years. We got the bill of rights in 1791,
uh, 12 amendments were sent out, 10 of them
were ratified. We call them today, the bill
of rights in 1800 or 1801 the problems, to
put it mildly, of the way we selected presidents
was revealed in the time between Thomas Jefferson
and Aaron Burr. And we got the 12th amendment,
which changed things for the better though
not enough as far as I'm concerned. And I'm
skipping the 11th amendment, which is much
more esoteric. But in 1793, the supreme court
issued a very controversial decision about
state's rights and it was reversed.
So if you look at our early history, you could
say, we know three quarters is a lot, but
the system is more or less working in the
modern world. Three quarters of 50 where you
have the distribution that you now have of
small states and indeed very small states,
and not only large states, but very large
states and a far, far more polarized country,
um, than even was the case in. Um, suddenly
in 87, it has become functionally close to
impossible to amend the constitution. So you
know, political scientists have looked at
that and looked at this and some have said
that the United States national constitution
is the most difficult to amend constitution
in the world. And one of the things we talk
about in our book, and frankly I think one
of the things that is especially valuable
about our book is that we look not only at
the u s constitution, but also at the fact
that every state has its own constitution.
There are 51 constitution in the United States
and if you look at the state constitutions,
they are all easier to amend then the national
constitution. So it's not the case that the
American people are reluctant to amend their
constitution. In fact, the typical state has
had close to three different constitutions
over their histories. Rather, we have a peculiar
religious like veneration of the national
constitution that makes it almost unthinkable
to talk about amending it. But even if you
do think of amending, you then come up against
the concrete reality that it's extraordinary
difficult to get two thirds of each house
of Congress. And then even if you get it,
it's even more difficult to get three quarters
of the states.
So one of the, um, areas that is of a, a lot
of interest right now because of the current
administration is the census and, uh, how
should it be carried out? What is really the
underlying purpose of the census from, from
a sort of constitutional historian perspective,
what was the point of establishing the census
to begin with?
Since it's an extraordinarily interesting
part of the constitution, because you can
make an argument that it's really one of the
very, very few things Congress must make sure
is done. The other is actually setting up
a supreme court of the United States. But
for example, setting up circuit courts or
district courts, that's optional with Congress.
It's optional for Congress to declare war
or not to declare wars, et Cetera, et cetera.
But the constitution requires that a census
be held every 10 years. And the reason is
deceptively simple. It's the House of Representatives
that the house is allocated more or less proportionately
unlike the u s senate. Um, and so if you're
going to have a major branch of Congress where
representation is a function of the population
of the states, you have to know the population
of the states. It's really as simple as that.
And it's every 10 years because the framers
were smart enough to realize that the United
States was, that I NAMIC country, there would
be lots of settlement, there would be people
moving around.
So you couldn't necessarily depend that the
population of Virginia in 1790 relative to
the population of, uh, Tennessee would be
the same in 1800 or 18, 20, et Cetera, et
cetera. So the constitution requires every
10 years without exception. Interestingly
in my reading, although it requires it, it's
not clear what the penalty would be and to
whom it would be assessed if the census does
not happen as scheduled as my reading. Correct
of that. Well, you know, it's one of those
things, John Marshall referred to the constitution
as a great outline. And so there are things
that are specified. One of them is you got
to have a census. But again, the question
you ask is a very shrewd one. What if the
president says, you know, I don't think so.
Um, then what do you do? Do you charge the
president with violating the law?
Well, actually this morning is being spent
on the molar hearings and hearing Robert Mower
saying over and over again, the Justice Department
says you can't indict a sitting president.
So could you impeach a president for refusing
to take care to enforce one of the most basic
obligations of the national government, which
is to conduct a census? I think the answer
is yes, but I think it would require a sense
of national outrage led by Congress that the
president is being derelict with regard to
one of his most fundamental responsibilities,
which is to make sure that the house representatives
is fairly apportioned. Yes.
Sending in today's a hyper partisan climate.
It's hard for me to imagine that there would
be, uh, that level of United notice, uh, around
that particular issue. But it remains to be
seen. Right.
I think you're right.
We've been speaking with Sanford Levinson,
who's a legal scholar professor at the University
of Texas law school. The book coauthored with
his wife Cynthia, his fault lines in the constitution,
the framers, their fights and the flaws that
affect us today. Sanford, really a pleasure
having you on.
Yeah, my pleasure.